[Música]
soy no los científico y hace años que
hago experimentos para tratar de
entender el comportamiento humano y
muchas veces en este camino el cine o la
literatura han sido la única manera de
imaginarnos cómo reaccionaríamos frente
a situaciones extraordinarias
desde grandes amores invasiones
extraterrestres hasta pandemias
hasta que la ficción se hizo realidad y
aquí y ahora en casa no dejamos de
hacernos preguntas desde los rincones
más extraordinarios de la condición
humana hasta los más ridículos y los más
mundanos
por ejemplo la obsesión mundial por
salir a comprar montañas de papel
higiénico resulta que este
comportamiento que parece y es ridículo
tiene una lógica inconsciente
en este caso el foco está más puesto en
la intensidad que en la pertinencia de
la respuesta es un poco como el
futbolista que corre desesperadamente
una pelota a la que en realidad sabe que
no va a llegar y es que el fracaso se
vive con más alivio si sabemos que hemos
hecho un gran esfuerzo para intentar
remediarlo
también es muy propio de lo humano el
tratar de buscar explicaciones aquello
que nos pasa en este caso el gobierno
chino en sólo 10 días no sólo había
encontrado el virus que produce la
enfermedad sino que había secuenciado su
genoma y lo había hecho público y esto
hubiese dado una gran ventaja de tiempo
al resto de nosotros de no ser por otro
principio la psicología humana llamada
el sesgo optimista lo mismo que hace que
muchos de nosotros manejemos o
conduzcamos mientras hablamos por
teléfono o peor mientras mandamos
mensajes pensando que en realidad a
nosotros no nos va a pasar nada hizo que
los grandes políticos de europa y de
muchos otros lugares del mundo pierdan
una gran oportunidad de actuar a tiempo
pero muchas veces las respuestas que
buscamos no son biológicas o médicas
sino que son más morales o sociales
porque nos pasa esto ahora a nosotros y
lamentablemente casi siempre estas
preguntas terminan en culpables o en
estigmas por ejemplo en la peste
bubónica se acusó a los judíos en europa
y a los chinos en san francisco en eeuu
cuando en realidad esto hizo que la
gente pierda una oportunidad de ver que
la ciudad se había convertido en un
cementerio de ratas que eran las que
realmente estaban propagando la
enfermedad
en esta pandemia como en muchas otras
las mascarillas son útiles sobre todo
para evitar que la gente que ya está
enferma contagia a otros sin embargo en
japón se ha dispuesto que todo el mundo
usen mascarillas esto primero hace que
la gente que está enferma no lo sabe lo
contagia esto es muy importante pero más
hay otra razón quizás más importante que
es que si sólo usas en mascarillas los
enfermos entonces todo sería una especie
de cruz acusatoria saber quién está
enfermo y quién no por si usan o no
mascarillas que la usen todo el mundo es
una manera de evitar el estigma y con
esto de cuidarnos a todos
quizá lo que más hayamos descubierto en
estos días es nuestra extraordinaria
capacidad para el cambio final
pensamos que resistimos en nuestras
tradiciones en nuestros hábitos en
nuestros vicios porque es imposible
cambiarnos pero lo cierto es creo que
nos falta realmente es motivación para
hacerlo
esto es descubierto ahora durante años
pensamos que la educación no podía
cambiar y que eran aquellas cosas que
era extremadamente difícil de
modificarla y sin embargo en tres días
ahora todos los chicos se educan en su
casa no sabemos aún las consecuencias de
esto pero sí hemos aprendido que estamos
dispuestos a hacerlo si la necesidad
apremia y el mundo sigue girando
también por supuesto cambian nuestros
valores nuestros juicios hace apenas dos
o tres meses cuando empezó la pandemia
la gente de occidente mirada china con
ojos acusatorios por su predisposición a
restringir las libertades individuales a
confinar la gente en su casa hoy lo que
entonces parecía horrible que todo el
mundo tengan que quedarse en su casa nos
parece completamente prioritario y sobre
esta idea cómo pueden cambiar nuestros
principios y cómo podemos ir ajustando
los me gustaría hacer un pequeño
experimento mental es un dilema una
caricatura para que pensemos sobre el
futuro
imagínense la siguiente situación
estamos al principio de la pandemia
un consorcio público que incluye a la
organización mundial de la salud pero
también a gobiernos y otros sectores
públicos tienen la capacidad a través de
alguna tecnología de saber dónde
estábamos donde nos movemos a quién
encontramos y también datos de nuestra
intimidad corporal nuestra temperatura
nuestra frecuencia respiratoria quizás
nuestra carga viral y puede usar esa
información para saber quién está
infectado o quién estar está en riesgo
de estar infectado y quién no
supongamos más aún que este consorcio
puede utilizar esta información para
restringir el movimiento de la gente de
una manera específica aquel que está en
riesgo se queda en casa el que no está
en riesgo puede salir y sigamos en este
experimento mental imaginando que con
esto realmente atenuamos enormemente el
efecto de la epidemia no desaparece
completamente pero se murió muchísima
menos gente y podemos hacerlo de una
manera donde no tenemos que parar la
economía y el mundo de la manera que lo
hemos hecho
por último pensemos que todas las
razones conspirativas
en general no queremos saber nuestros
datos el riesgo a que hagan un mal uso
de ellos sigue siendo cierto no hay nada
gratis
la pregunta es si estuviese al principio
la pandemia y pudieses elegir si te
parece bien o mal hacer esto qué harías
elegí este dilema porque creo que esboza
la tensión inevitable que hay entre por
un lado la privacidad y la libertad
individual que son valores fundamentales
pilares de nuestra cultura y por el otro
lado las soluciones colectivas que son
necesarias y las más eficientes para
resolver pandemias
quizás se vean nuestros datos sea un
poco como vacunarnos es una concesión
que hacemos de una de nuestras muchas
libertades como parte de un pacto social
para cuidarnos a nosotros y a todos
hace un tiempo con el h y ve también una
suerte de jaque a la libertad en este
caso a la libertad sexual y encontramos
una buena solución de compromiso sexo
con preservativo cuando pase todo esto
cuál será el equilibrio al que queremos
llegar para sentirnos a la vez libres y
cuidados
acaso van a volar menos aviones en el
cielo
acaso cambiaremos la manera de
saludarnos acaso aceptaremos que está
bien dar parte de nuestros datos como un
bien público para cuidarnos a todos
no lo sabemos pero encerrados en casa
tenemos una oportunidad para pensar más
libremente que nunca cuál queremos que
sea el sexo con preservativo del
coronavirus
[Aplausos]